check this out I'm charging my phone
without any wires or a battery pack and
this gaming controller never needs to be
plugged in Imagine never having to plug
in any of this because of this thing
this is the transmitter and that's where
the power is coming from so why aren't
we charging everything through the air
and how can this be safe I'll explain
companies offering air charging
generally pick one of three ways to
remotely power your device radio waves
microwaves or infrared light the
specific Tech powering these gadgets
comes from Israeli tech company y charge
which uses infrared light we have a
transmitter which is like an inner solar
that delivers an invisible infrared beam
and the receiver converts the infrared
beam back into electricity there's no
battery in this so if I remove the paper
it'll just go eventually yep and we're
not doing Lego train as a product this
is the coolest way that we found to
demonstrate over the air charging why
infrared specifically when you actually
want to deliver meaningful power over
meaningful distance with small receiver
that can fit inside every consumer
electronic device you have to use
infrared it's similar to the infrared
used in TV remote controls but TV
remotes send the signal in many
directions which is good for simple low
power data communication why charge
beams the signal directionally in a
straight line to the device and follows
it allowing power to be transferred it's
a slow process though or it says phones
would charge much slower over the air
compared to wall plug charging which
isn't so bad since battery experts say
that batteries have a longer lifespan
when you charge them slowly and slow
charging doesn't matter as much if
you're continuously getting Juiced and
aren't held back by a power cord
this concept isn't new it's been more
than a century since Nikola Tesla wowed
crowds by powering electric lamps at a
distance
where are the wires
exactly but doing that safely inside
people's homes that took some time since
we can now make things operate at much
higher frequencies we can make the
gadgets that transmit this energy
smaller so it's now small enough to fit
in a cell phone or an iPad or a laptop
for even higher Powers okay okay I know
what you're thinking how in this be safe
am I going to grow another head or
something the general limit these days
it is about one watt of power so it's
it's just very small a standard light
bulb is 60 watts so it's even less than
that experts tell me that wireless power
transfer is generally safe as long as
companies adhere to frequency and power
output guidelines set by the FCC FDA and
others y charge says the fda's criteria
ensures the devices don't cause
radiation issues or interference with
nearby devices the FDA approval means it
needs to be safe enough for a small kid
to take it put it in in front of his eye
or something else and still it needs to
be safe under all conditions so why
don't we have it in our homes yet for a
long time no one really needed it but
today data shows that on average
consumers have more than 20 connected
devices at home with more smartphones
and smart gadgets there's more of a
financial incentive for companies to
make juicing up easier Samsung has a new
remote that sips on Wi-Fi signals solar
power and ambient light to charge itself
over the air and startups have ideas too
the Washington state-based Firm asea
made this product that could turn a
regular double A battery into an air
chargeable one and the california-based
startup energis says it can power
digital price tags at stores over the
air a couple of things still need to
happen though before devices like this
go mainstream first Wireless power
companies need to keep growing their
customer base right now air charging
devices are most often found in
warehouses and businesses which have the
scale and more immediate need for the
tech as more buy-in startups
theoretically have more money to invest
in advancing the technology further and
bring costs down over time ultimately
for widespread consumer adoption you
really need big name companies like
Apple and Samsung to support it then
manufacturers would need to incorporate
over-the-air charging capabilities into
devices think TV laptops and other
household gadgets that involves
modifying internal parts to support a
new way of receiving power that's an
expensive undertaking that alone could
take years and most importantly
consumers must be interested in the tech
for it to show up in more stuff even
though over-the-air power is way slower
than plugging your phone in like this
I'd rather have my device's trickle
charged all day than deal with these and
who actually wants to have to remember
to charge their toothbrush not me
foreign